BRADY HARAN: A little while
back, we spoke to Alex from
Bite Sci-zed about her
number/color synesthesia,
basically how she sees
numbers as colors.
The video created a lot of
interest and a lot of comments
from you guys as viewers.
One of the things you did was
you all sent in what color you
think numbers are.
We've taken that information and
done a bit of work with it
to create a few graphs
and other things.
But I'll have more about that
at the end of the video.
The other thing was
you had loads of
questions for Alex herself.
Now, a little while
ago, I caught up
with her at an event.
And I had all of
your questions.
So I sat her down and
asked some of them.
Now, one of the things a lot
of you said was you thought
she was making it up.
So I asked Alex that.
ALEX DAINIS: No.
Why?
BRADY HARAN: How do we know
you're not making it up?
ALEX DAINIS: I guess
it's hard.
I mean, as a scientist, I
encourage skepticism.
And I want to be able to show
you in my head and show you
data points.
But I can't.
You're just going to have
to take my word for it.
BRADY HARAN: Have you
been to a doctor?
Has it been diagnosed?
ALEX DAINIS: I haven't,
actually.
That's a good point.
I know that I make these
associations between numbers
and colors very strongly.
And synesthesia is the best
word that I have found to
describe that.
BRADY HARAN: Do the numbers give
you the colors or do the
colors give you the numbers?
ALEX DAINIS: The numbers
give me the colors.
So if I see a color,
it doesn't back
translate into a number.
But if I see a number, then
I can see the color.
It helps me to memorize
things.
It's really good for memorizing
phone numbers.
BRADY HARAN: So another thing
that came up in the previous
video was that sometimes the
color of a number was created
by its factors.
So some of you asked, could Alex
take a number, look at
its color, and then reverse
engineer the factors just by
using the color?
So I asked.
ALEX DAINIS: No,
unfortunately.
The factors influence the
color of the number if I
already know them.
So for something like 14, 7 is
such a huge part of 14 to me
that that yellow is really
prominent in there.
But if I see a giant number, I
unfortunately cannot see a
color with it and
pull it back.
BRADY HARAN: How do you
see prime numbers?
ALEX DAINIS: So it depends
really on what the
prime number is.
So something like 13, it's
really a 1 and a 3.
It has a lot more to do
with their digits.
Only the things, really, from
zero to nine have their own
specific colors if they're
prime numbers.
One on its own is just white,
if it's just a single digit.
But when it can be combined with
other things-- so in 10
and 100 and 1,000--
then it takes on that sort
of black flicker, almost.
BRADY HARAN: If you see numbers
written down on a
piece of paper in black print,
which is the most common
thing, do they become
colorful for you?
ALEX DAINIS: No.
So when they're still on that
page, they just exist in
whatever color they are,
whatever color that print is.
But when I think about that
number, when it moves into my
head, then it takes
on the color.
But the ink on the page
stays the same color.
I, unfortunately, do not
think about numbers
and bases very often.
And so I think because my brain
really works on a base
10 system, it's just the digits
zero to nine that have
their own colors.
If I were to think in base six,
I would still just see
the digit one, five, and
not translate it.
BRADY HARAN: Is mathematics a
sort of colorful, psychedelic
experience?
ALEX DAINIS: I don't think
I would consider to be
psychedelic.
It is colorful.
I mean, I am seeing these
colors in my mind.
But because that's just the way
I've always experienced
the numbers, it's
not weird to me.
It's not distracting to me.
Just, they are numbers.
BRADY HARAN: A lot of other
people who responded to this
video said that for
them, numbers have
personalities or genders.
Do you associate personalities
or genders with any numbers?
ALEX DAINIS: I do.
So that's actually how I sort of
realized that I was seeing
these colors is that I had had
that gut reaction in class
that numbers have personalities,
not colors.
And so I think the example I
gave before is that nine is a
very dark red.
And so it seems like sort of
an angry number to me.
Whereas the two, four,
and eights are
sort of cooler numbers.
And they seem a little
bit more chill.
bit more friendly.
But that's really sort of
the realm of things are.
Seven is not intrinsically
jealous because it's yellow,
but sort of basic personalities
of nice or mean.
BRADY HARAN: Gender?
ALEX DAINIS: No gender, no.
BRADY HARAN: Can you give me
a color for these numbers,
because these are just numbers
people asked for?
ALEX DAINIS: Sure.
BRADY HARAN: 79.
ALEX DAINIS: 79 is yellow,
and that nine,
maroon at the same time.
BRADY HARAN: So it's not like
you've mixed paints.
It's two things?
ALEX DAINIS: It is for
a much of the larger
digit numbers, yeah.
So things that are, I would say,
probably below 40, is a
lot more mixing, I think,
because I do know those
factors and I've thought about
those numbers a lot more.
But the higher ones is really
just the digits.
It's as if you had two colored
sheets of cling film, one that
was yellow and one that was that
maroon, and sort of laid
them over each other.
So it's not really like
you're mixing paints.
I understand that they're
two separate things.
But they're existing
in the same space.
BRADY HARAN: 854,685,254.
ALEX DAINIS: As you're saying
them, I can see the blue,
black, blue.
But it does not exist as one
whole number in my head.
BRADY HARAN: And now I'll
show it to you.
There you go.
I'm showing it to you now.
ALEX DAINIS: Oh yeah, still.
So the digits all have
their own thing.
But I think because I'm not
processing the quantity that
is that large number, just
the digits have their own
identities.
BRADY HARAN: Fractions?
ALEX DAINIS: Fractions
just look like a
digit over a digit.
Negative numbers, the negative
doesn't have any
impact on the colors.
BRADY HARAN: Irrational
numbers.
So how do you deal with pi?
ALEX DAINIS: With pi.
So pi as a symbol doesn't
have anything.
It's just a symbol.
But if I think of 3.14, then
it does take on the red,
white, and blue.
I can do pi to 22 digits.
BRADY HARAN: Go.
ALEX DAINIS: I hope
I still can.
3.141592653589793238462.
BRADY HARAN: Was anything
colorful happening
in your head then?
ALEX DAINIS: I mean,
as I say the digit,
I can see the color.
But it's not cramming itself
all into one big color.
BRADY HARAN: i, and
complex numbers,
and imaginary numbers.
ALEX DAINIS: Again, they don't
have digits to me.
And so if I think of i as a
number, I guess, then it does.
But i itself is just i.
BRADY HARAN: The final thing is
a lot of people responded
to what you had to say in the
last video, and understood
what you were saying, but
completely disagreed about the
colors, said Alex is wrong.
That's not that color.
It's this color.
And they even gave whole
sets of what they
think the colors are.
What do you say to that?
ALEX DAINIS: I completely
understand that, because I've
seen people give me those
sets as well.
And I have that same reaction
of no, that's wrong.
It's such an intrinsic link to
me that I don't get that
people can--
I mean, I understand logically
that people
can see other colors.
But no, three is red.
I don't know what--
green is three, people
are saying.
Three is red.
BRADY HARAN: What
is five again?
ALEX DAINIS: Five is black.
BRADY HARAN: So look at those
five chairs there.
ALEX DAINIS: Yes.
BRADY HARAN: What do you
feel about that?
ALEX DAINIS: It's funny
because if I don't--
I mean, it's fine.
This does not impede my
life, but it is wrong.
I think it's more with things
under 10, because you can see
the quantity and understand
at the same time.
If I had to count every chair
in here, I wouldn't be very
upset that all the white chairs,
if there were 20 white
chairs and they were all white,
that would be fine.
But now that you've brought
it up, it's not right.
BRADY HARAN: So thanks so much
to Alex for talking to us more
about this subject which so many
of you find interesting.
Now also, all of those comments
from last time and
all of the colors that you guys
attributed to numbers
have been analyzed by Dave
Wiley, our resident graph
number expert who
helps us out.
And he's come up with this.
This is a graph showing
the most popular
colors for each number.
This is going to
be on my blog.
So have a look at the link under
the video description if
you want to pore over
this in more detail.
But also, Dave has put
this together.
Based on the HSV Color Space,
this is the average color of
each number.
So here we go.
Zero, one, two, three,
four, five--
a lot of greens you can see--
six, seven, eight.
Again, more green.
But then we go 9, 10,
11, 12, 13, 14, 15.
And this is where Dave stopped
for now, because the data
started getting a bit
thin after that.
19 of you said that numbers to
you seem to have genders.
13 people said the days of
the week have colors.
And the area of most agreement
amongst all of you as viewers
was that the number
27 is green.
So there you have it.
This video has been brought you
by Squarespace, which is
an all-in-one platform for
designing your own websites,
blogs, portfolios,
online stores.
They've got a whole range of
templates you can use to get
your site looking just
how you want.
But then you can customize it.
You can choose your
own colors.
Maybe you're going to choose
green after this video.
But you can get it just
how you like.
And one of the best things about
it is you can design
your website and it
automatically changes for
people who are viewing
it on mobile phones.
So check it out.
Here's the website.
Here's what some of those
websites can look like.
You can sign on for free.
And if you decide to buy
anything, you can get 10% off
by using the code
numberphile5.
Squarespace.com, numberphile5
for the discount.
And thanks to Squarespace for
supporting Numberphile and
making videos like
this possible.